along forest roads and across farmland
ukrainian forces race to fortify the
donbass
every day brings new
fighting with russian artillery hitting
the small villages on the front line
black smolders on the horizon
eventually we reach alexandrevka
russian forces are about two kilometers
away
and it's now almost deserted
as we follow the soldier tells us to use
the trees as cover
there are drones above he wants and
standing in the open here can get you
killed
this is where it landed today
the smoke over there you can see
the places that are being shelled at the
moment and then one just landed over
here
bistro
he shows us a farm it's too dangerous to
go further he says it's just been struck
the family escaped but it soon comes
under attack again
let's go guys come
on mate let's go let's go
everyone's good yeah everyone's good
get it guys let's go
well again
this place has come under attack
they've managed to get everybody out of
the village
but we need to leave now too
millions of ukrainians have been
displaced or trapped by this conflict
the front lines are shifting here all
the time
and as russian forces advance many
villages like this one are now in the
firing line
foreign
nearby this group of medics takes a
break behind the front line
a chance to grab rest and share food
under the cover of the woodlands
every day is difficult treating comrades
but they are convinced putin's forces
can be defeated
[Music]
this war is now entering its third month
and as ukraine reinforces its army in
the east with fresh soldiers and new
weapons
its army knows the next few weeks will
be decisive
alex rossi sky news eastern ukraine